a guide to the flora and fauna of the
world is publication which accompanies
the exhibition of the same name at a
Singapore Banali 2013 it is a work by
Robert who is an artist and publication
consists of 55 plates and it comes with
supporting documents well Roberts work
in this case specifically talks about
how humans use science and technology to
intervene with nature he was quite open
brief which was given to us by Robert so
basically I had to narrow down our scope
and define some parameters for the
project on this project actually does
fairly totemo the theme of the
collaborative process was really between
me and Robert the artist we had a lot of
fruitful compositions in his studio we
were surrounded by loved animals and
plants and strange specimens and so that
really spurred a lot of ideas between us
two of us
as a graphic designer what I would
normally do is to create a visual
representation of a client's world but
in this case because of the nature of
the project and also Robert being an
artist we want to present his work in a
pure form so that his voice is not
drowned by ours but at the same time how
do we justify our existence as a
creative person if we were not to
intervene in some way so needs to always
be a fine balance with such a project oh
it's definitely significant to be
recognized nationally definitely with
encouragement not just for myself but
for anyone who are with this award
my advice to young designers would be to
look beyond design and not let design be
a limitation to how you see things this
is a guide to the flora and fauna of the
world design of the year
you